une production du studio sf
bio sans filtre le podcast on parle de
convaincre nos invités date cette upm
quentin avec moins d'hommes plan nous
mêmes vous avez un projet pas de castres
voulait mener votre podcast un autre
niveau vous pouvez louer un de nous
trois espaces ici au studio sfr n'a le
studio sf que dans lequel on enregistre
nous notre podcast on a ici le bout des
doigts ou est ce qu'on est en train
d'enregistrer l'introduction cependant t
on un nouvel espace plus grand et plus
lumineux qu'on vous dévoiler sous peu et
dont on cherche un nom mais bien vous
pourrez sûrement pote gay c'est un nom
avant de voir l'espace la pole avant
l'heure
bref si vous voulez louer ou avoir plus
d'information dirigée vous au studio est
ce point c'est en cette semaine de cette
semaine grand plaisir de recevoir julien
tourreille qui déjà venu sur le podcast
qui voudraient parler de la situation en
afghanistan qu'ils barque
aujourd'hui du conflit bien sûr en
ukraine conflit entre la russie
l'ukraine julien guerrier et enseignants
de gamme en science politique et
chercheur à la chaire raoul dandurand
dans la personne idéale pour nous
expliquer veut vraiment clairement se
confie lieu quels sont les acteurs
impliqués qu'est ce que ça implique
justement question des conséquences en
compte des conflits comme ce pourquoi on
en est arrivé là moi j'ai énormément
appris les conversations le jeu comprend
vraiment beaucoup mieux ce conflit le et
j'ai l'impression que vous savez faire
de grandes choses vous êtes très
nombreux à avoir écrit à lui faire un
podcast sur ce sujet le alors et voilà
qu'on vous le feront le tour n'est le
lundi de pâques à 100 la mort du donc ça
ce qui est des situations créées évolué
depuis mai
pour comprendre vraiment plus largement
ce conflit je pense que ça va rester
quand même intemporelle la formation qui
était dit dans ce pack est tout à fait
sans plus attendre ou laisse à la
conversation mais juste avant on va
aller remercier nos commencer
le podcast de cette semaine et présenté
par un pot à distance est beau à
distance c'est ça que j'aime c'est ça
que je pense pas qu'on peut le prendre
encore un peu à distance
c'est un service de déclaration d'impôts
pour particulier le temps des impôts
c'est à nos portes en fait il n'y a pas
grand chose qui me crée plus d'anxiété
que l'impôt parce que tu sais pas par où
prendre se sait pas quoi faire avec tout
ce bien un pot à distance il offre un
service dans le confort de votre salon
vous n'avez pas besoin de vous déplacer
vous pouvez faire ça même votre
cellulaire fait que c'est que d'être
proof ça vous pouvez parler un humain
aucun appel rien juste rappeler notre
formule à prendre d'affaires en photos
envoyées toute la
documentation vous avez besoin le petit
souci ces banques là qui s'occupe de vos
impôts reste juste à payer vos impôts à
la toute fin le moins d'impôt possible
évidemment est en promo csf 20 pour 20%
de rabais sur des prix qui sont déjà
extrêmement abordables paquet pour pays
le moins cher possible pour vous imposer
un poète stoch puis on avait ses impôts
le site web en fait c'est un pot
distance points comme fait qu'on va le
mettre dans la destruction de podcasts
puis juste pour l'anecdote
moi j'ai en fait on fait les impôts du
studio puis honnêtement quand tu es pro
pris en charge c'est vraiment compliqué
fake assurez vous d'être pris en charge
par les bonnes personnes merci impôts à
distance de commanditer les enfants
le pot cas de cette semaine et présenté
par optio pierre
vous savez peut-être moins que
personnellement j'ai des preuves avec
mes compagnies de télécommunications
avec qui j'ai pas peur parce quelqu'un
qui a des problèmes avec mon service et
appelle tout le temps compliquée dans sa
facture s'est jamais de bruit dû penser
que ça va être tout le temps plus
charger tout le temps vraiment complexe
ce n'est pas le cas avec option qui est
le plus grand fournisseur indépendant
d'internet au québec parlement plus
d'hommes et sélectionne aussi cox ue le
ils vous prennent pas parti ouais
options it then ils vous prennent pour
acquis pis
ça vaut tout le temps à être cette
claire peut-être cinq comme tu le disais
souvent compliqué mais c'est vrai tout
accompli et apl qui vit et l'on s'est
compliquée la meute se rend compte que
des fautes plus chaleureux très moi
j'adore ton voisin lui paye plus cher et
moins cher roxio c'est clair c'est
simple il ya pas de bullshit l'epo bien
d'autres que le meilleur service qui
peut vous après il laisserait sa
clientèle est vraiment sur la coche et
rapide et efficace dont la plateforme
est optimisé tout est fait pour ça et le
mieux possible ça va bien aller avec oxo
yes puis on a un code vraiment pour vous
qui le sans fil pour un mois d'essai
gratuit après ceux ci voulaient
retourner à votre à vos anciennes pente
of les bravos de la forme et vous
garantis que vous le ferez pas une autre
affaire aussi qui est intéressante avec
lexus et que leurs prix sont ventilés
fait que les prix sont les meilleurs
tricks peuvent offrir que vous pouvez la
voir sur le site web ou est-ce que votre
argent vaut comme ce n'est pas comme
en inde de bonne chair et en os xi au
point ca au xxi au point ca merci
beaucoup de supporter le papier
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci beaucoup d'être leur ce matin ses
plaisirs la dernière minute comme selon
nous faut agir rapidement qu'en cas de
force majeure
donc merci d'avoir pu faire simple on
prend le temps en fait de dire aux
initiales manque que le titre va sortir
demain exaspère qu'il ya des nouveautés
oui ça change très vite un petit peu
comme quand tu étais venu pour nous
parler du conflit en afghanistan
j'aimerais ça qu'on essaie de comprendre
comme un conte s'est rendu le puits pour
pouvoir ensuite voir quels sont les
les prospects de d'avenir en fait la
veille initialement comment est-ce que
ce conflit là est venu à voir le jour
je vais pas remonter trop trop trop loin
dans l'histoire mais si on veut voir des
facteurs plus conjoncturelle dans une
perspective assez assez brève il faut
revenir à peu près à 2014 en 2014
vladimir poutine décide d'une opération
militaire en ukraine
en réponse à ce qu'il perçoit comme des
aspirations ukrainienne de s'éloigner de
la sphère d'influencé russe et
s'éloigner de la sphère d'influencé
russe ça voulait dire se rapprocher de
l'occident avec peut-être à terme
adhérer à des organisations
internationales qui sont très connoté
occidental à savoir l'union européenne
et possiblement l'otan donc en 2014 pour
faire en sorte que l'ukraine n'adhère
pas à ces institutions ne quitte pas la
sphère d'influencé russe vladimir
poutine décide d'une opération militaire
qui se traduit notamment par l'annexion
de la crimée une région où et qui était
jusqu'en 2014 partie intégrante de
l'ukraine qui est depuis
retourné dans le giron russe et laisse
vladimir poutine dans deux régions
séparatistes à l'est de l'ukraine ce
qu'on appelle le donbass des forces
militaires nombreuses qui sont présentes
depuis 2014 donc on est à la base dans
ce contexte là qui perdure depuis huit
ans est ce qui est assez fascinant c'est
que donc il ya quelques jours vladimir
poutine a décidé de passer à la vitesse
supérieure estimant qu'il y avait encore
à ses yeux cette menace que l'ukraine
quitte la sphère d influence russe mais
il ya quelque chose de très nouveau qui
a peut-être changé notamment son final
discours qu'il a publié un texte qu'il a
publiés en juillet 2021 c'est non
seulement qu'il avait peur que l'ukraine
aille vers le camp occidental mais
surtout ils dénient à l'ukraine son
droit même d'exister il nie la
légitimité de l'ukraine comme état
souverain et il n'y même l'existence
d'une nation ukrainienne indépendante
c'est un peu comme un charme contrôler
un qui veut pas laisser aller sa
partenaire qui essaient de contrôler son
excès de la contrôler puis de l'empêcher
d'aller voir qu'est ce qui se passe
ailleurs dans le monde oui oui c'est oui
l'analogie assez intéressante cet ex si
on peut ainsi l'ukraine faisait partie
alors là si on revient un petit peu plus
en arrière dans l'histoire faisait
partie de l'union soviétique et l'union
soviétique a implosé au tout début des
années 90 mais les ukrainiens ont décidé
par référendum massif d'être indépendant
donc de ne plus être associée carte du
massif
une idée des pourcentages de série n 10
pour ça qu'il y avait vraiment une
grande majorité de supporteurs oui oui
et c'est en ce sens que lorsqu'on entend
ou lorsqu'on évoque le fait que poutine
ni l'existence même d'une nation
ukrainienne où le droit être un état
souverain et indépendant
il ya quelque chose qui cloche et qui
est contraire à la réalité telle qu'elle
a été exprimée il ya une trentaine
d'années donc oui
il y là ce malaise
ce ressentiment à l'endroit donc que ce
pays existe de façon indépendante parce
que plus largement et ça a été je crois
a évoqué très très très souvent poutine
considère que l'un des drames
le drame géopolitique du 20e siècle ça a
été la dissolution de l'urss et si on
part de ce postulat on peut considérer
que tout ça son action sur la scène
internationale toute sa politique
étrangère consisterait à quelque part
restaurer une forme d'union soviétique
ou resterait une forme d'impérialisme
russe dans sa zone d influence dont il
estime que l'ukraine fait partie au même
titre par exemple que la géorgie où il
est déjà intervenue en 2008 pour
exactement les mêmes raisons la georgie
laissé entendre ou aspiré à se
rapprocher de l'occident il a utilisé le
même mode opératoire appuyer des
groupuscules pro-russe dans des
provinces séparatistes et la biélorussie
fait par exemple aujourd'hui partie très
très clairement de la zone d influence
de moscou donc on est dans cette vision
du monde qui est propre à vladimir
poutine qui s'ajoute aussi parce que ça
a été souvent évoquée à
ressentiment qu'il a vis-à-vis du
comportement des occidentaux notamment
de l'élargissement de l'otan à partir du
milieu des années 90 et du début des
années 2000 donc l'organisation du
traité de l'atlantique nord qui avait
été créé pour faire face à l'urss
pendant la guerre froide et claire en
1949 et lorsque l'urss a disparu mais
cette organisation n'a pas disparu et au
contraire petit à petit elle a intégré
d'anciens pays qui faisait partie du
bloc soviétique pendant la guerre froide
et on l'a longtemps considéré que
poutine voyez ça comme une menace et que
toutes ses actions elle était
destinée à freiner cette menace là je
dis on a longtemps considéré ça parce
que le conflit craignant et la façon
dont il se joue ce conflit craignent une
guerre totale sur la totalité du
territoire laissent à penser qu'il n'y a
pas que ça dans la volonté de poutine ou
dans les facteurs qui l'ont poussé à
lancer cette guerre
depuis tantôt
quand quand tu parles de poutine tu mens
tu mentionnes seulement lui est ce que
c'est parce que il
y piller le seul maître décisionnel de
l'ensemble la russie
à l'heure actuelle je pense que ça fait
assez peu de doute que c'est lui qui lui
seul pour ses propres aspirations sans
considération pour
des conseillers externes c'est assez
fascinant de regarder les images à cet
égard des rencontres qui peut avoir avec
ses différents conseillers je pense que
c'était en début de semaine dernière
lundi dernier il a convoqué son conseil
de sécurité nationale dans une immense
salle ce coupole au kremlin où la
distanciation sociale là c'était pas
deux mètres de lettres quasiment va
mettre inclus voilà entre ses propres
conseillers il ya quelques heures au
cours du week-end il a convoqué des
grades et des hauts gradés de l'armée
est là aussi la distance est très très
grande alors ça peut paraître
anecdotique parler cette distance la
longueur des tables mais c'est aussi
significatif
tête de l'isolément dans lequel il ait
beaucoup d'observateurs et de
politiciens sur la scène internationale
qui connaissent poutine qu'ils ont déjà
pratiqué qu'ils ont déjà fréquenté
souligne à quel point il est peut-être
devenu
paranoïaque ou quelque chose qui va
passer plus le personnage aussi
rationnel qu'on aimait à décrire avant
beaucoup de gens aimés a présenté
poutine comme ce fameux joueur d'échecs
qui a toujours un coup d'avancé sur les
autres qui sait très bien manipuler les
vulnérabilités notamment les dissensions
entre pays occidentaux et là il ya il ya
quelque chose qui a changé c'est assez
significatif de voir par exemple que
l'ancienne chancelière allemande angela
merkel encore récemment disait que
manifestement il ya quelque chose
mentalement j'ai poutine qui a changé je
dirais pas qu'il est devenu fou je pense
ça serait faire trop de cas mais aussi
lorsque le président français il manuel
macron l'a rencontré il ya quelques
semaines avec justement cet épisode de
la grande table la cave et puis faire
rire ou vous faire sourire l'une des
conclusions qui a été tirée et par le
président français et le des membres de
la délégation française s'était que là
aussi qu'elle quelque chose
quelque chose avait changé et certaines
évoquent peut-être un effet de la
pandémie de covile 19 ou alors peut-être
poutine a très peur d'attraper cette
maladie là mais il a été isolé depuis
deux ans et isolées depuis deux ans il
sort aurait pu nourrir une certaine
paranoïa qui vient s'ajouter à un
ressentiment profond puisque on disait
hier il ya un instant lui est convaincu
que la russie a été humilié par les
occidentaux à travers cette processus
d'élargissement de l'otan à des anciens
pays qui étaient sous sous influence
russe et qui s'approche de la frontière
russe alors là il y avait quelque chose
comme un dilemme de sécurité qu'on
appelle en relations internationales
parce que par exemple les états baltes
qui était bon sur la sphère soviétique
mais sont aujourd'hui membres de l'otan
ils sont frontaliers de la russie donc
ça veut dire qu'il ya des alliés des
etats unis quand une frontière directe
avec la russie ce qui s'était pas passé
évidemment pendant la guerre froide mais
cette crête elle aurait pu être géré et
c'est ce qu'on ne pouvait l'imaginer de
façon sont toutes très rationnel parce
que un dilemme de sécurité vous pouvez
dialoguer trouver des des formulations
qui font que tout le monde est d'accord
on va avoir un contrôle des armements
mais là on est encore une fois on est
passé dans autre chose
et peut-être parce que aussi avec ce qui
se passait en ukraine dans le mouvement
démocratique qui en ukraine vladimir
poutine voyez il menace à la survie de
son propre régime est tout dictateur
n'aime pas trop elle menacée quand ils
se soient menacés ils préfèrent des
choses
qu'est ce qui explique encore m halte-là
entre la russie pipi l'occident
aujourd'hui ce que c'est il ya eu la
guerre froide sur meetic aujourd'hui
qu'il ya encore on dire est ce que
cette garde des gaules a presque le
entre l'occident pilaire oui alors il ya
beaucoup de malentendus
peut-être là dedans une incapacité à
trouver les mots justes a raté peut-être
d occasion de rapprochement parce que
alors il faut pas oublier que après donc
la dissolution de l'urss ans lorsque par
exemple de george bush père président et
les états unis il ya eu quand même une
main tendue à l'endroit de moscou pour
essayer d'amortir le choc de l'implosion
de l'union soviétique parce que
quasiment du jour au lendemain l'union
soviétique superpuissance mondiale se
transformer en russie pays
potentiellement port avec sur les bras
par exemple un arsenal nucléaire
gigantesque qui valait sécuriser les les
occidentaux américains en tête ont
participé ont aidé matériellement
humainement financièrement à la
sécurisation de cet arsenal nucléaire
les occidentaux ont espéré pendant les
années 90 en russie notamment sous la
présidence de boris eltsine qui est une
forme d'émergence d'une économie de
marché qui s'accompagnerait d'une
démocratisation
du pays et
après par exemple le long septembre 2001
george w bush donc le fils du précédent
à imaginer même qu'il pourrait y avoir
une entente avec la russie dans le cadre
de la lutte contre le terrorisme je
pense était le lendemain d'une rencontre
à prague entre les deux hommes que w
bush avait dit un truc du genre j'ai vu
dans les yeux de poutine son âme et
c'est quelqu'un de bien avec lequel on
peut dialoguer barack obama qu'elle
arrivait au pouvoir avait annoncé un
reset de la relation entre les deux pays
parce que b contrairement à ce qu'avait
dit w bush au début de son mandat à la
fin de son mandat ça s'était conclue par
la rivalité sur la question de la
georgie ans
minutes que je veux qu'il fallait donc
il ya eu des occasions ratées et chez
poutine il ya encore une fois par
rapport à ce que je disais sur qu'il le
fait qu'ils considèrent que la
disparition de l'urss c'est la
catastrophe géopolitique du 20e siècle
il ya ce sentiment d'avoir étaient
humiliés parce que lui il estime que
alors que la russie est fm dans les
années 90 peut-être jusqu'au début des
années 2000 grosso modo jusqu'à ce
qu'ils arrivent au pouvoir ah on a les
occidentaux en général
profiter de cette faiblesse là pour
avancer nos pions notamment élargir
l'otan et il sent pour lui c'est ces
menaces il sent le pays encerclé par un
ancien adversaire
héréditaire et en plus il sent que des
pays qui étaient dans cette fameuse zone
la différence de la russie veulent lui
échapper et se tourner vers vers
l'occident alors quand vous imaginez
comme il le fait que l'ukraine est le
berceau de la nation russe ou et que ce
berceau là où cet enfant là décident
d'aller regarder vers vos anciens
ennemis héréditaires
non seulement vous n'êtes pas contents
mais en plus vous êtes inquiet parce que
si vous pensez que les ukrainiens sont
pareils que vous sont et rude mais qui
peuvent avoir une démocratie alors que
vous avez imposées depuis 20 ans un
régime de plus en plus autoritaire ça
peut aussi donner des idées aux russes
qui désirent s nous sont les paris que
des ukrainiens on pourrait aussi avoir
une démocratie quand même
des facteurs qui passe près d'un an est
ce qu'on peut penser que l'agenda
finalement finale de poutine ça serait
dessus de 1 peut reconstruire ce qui
était autrefois l'urss en ré annexant
certain que le digérer annexée la crimée
qu'une région l'ukraine à la russie est
ce qu'on peut penser qu'ils voudraient
annexée l'ukraine a au complet à la
russie alors en poutine a peut-être deux
objectifs le premier c'était de
restaurer le prestige de la russie et
avec ça une forme de respect à l'endroit
de la russie parce qu'il estime que
c'est un grand pays qui a
un poids sur la scène internationale
dont il faut respecter les intérêts ça
c'est somme toute tout à fait légitime
son deuxième objectif oui c'est
peut-être de reconstituer une forme d'
empire russe de ré amalgames et des
territoires qu'il estime voilà entre
segments liés
à la russie et en ce sens ce qui peut
être fait en sorte qu'aujourd'hui il
fallait aujourd'hui il ya quelques jours
il a décidé de carrément changer de plan
de match par rapport à ceux qui nous
avaient habitués pour déstabiliser des
pays de l'étranger dans la zone
d'influencé traditionnelle
russes et essayer de le réintégrer dans
toute
son intégralité mais ça ça voudrait dire
occupée l'ukraine est
occupé un pays les roues c'est énorme
comme un grave grands pays dont les gens
n'ont certainement pas envie d'être sous
documentation russes ont manifestement
qui est géographiquement voilà qui très
grand qui équipe au plus le 15 millions
d'habitants on a l'impression que
vladimir poutine il a un peu oublié
l'histoire délicate de l'union
soviétique en afghanistan il va essayer
d'occuper le pays s'est pas très bien
passé et même sans aller jusqu'à
l'afghanistan dans les années qu'on en
parlait à ce qu'ils peuvent
sectionnement de quoi on parle vous
pouvez retourner à notre dernier cas ce
qu'on a fait ensemble auraient tout à
fait et ils oublient même ce qui est
arrivé aux etats-unis que ce soit en
afghanistan plus récemment ou ou en irak
même la puissance américaine n'a pas été
capable de paix d'occuper correctement
des pays étrangers et s'imaginer qu'ils
pourraient le faire
avec l'ukraine voilà il ya quelque part
une erreur de calcul de vladimir poutine
ici puis cette région la région de la
crimée qui a été annoncé c'est parce que
la majorité des habitants le ils sont
déjà russophone qui pro-russe j'imagine
pourquoi ça s'est fait aussi facilement
animés ou manette en main alors la
position de la crimée
elle pose toujours un peu de difficulté
ou ou débat parce que la crimée avait
été offerte par les dirigeants
soviétiques dans les années cinquante à
l'ukraine
mais
il y a une population russophone qui se
sentent plus proches de la russie qui
est elle était restée là est par
ailleurs la crimée à l'eau qu une
position géographique stratégique sur
sur la mer noire donc vladimir poutine
en 2014 il avait 2 incitatif finalement
à ré annexée où a récupéré la crimée le
fait donc la position stratégique avait
évidemment pas changé et que ça permet
d'avoir à la russie un meilleur accès
sur la mer loi dont pour des
considérations encore une fois
stratégique et par ailleurs il y avait
cette population qui
pouvait être un petit peu plus favorable
d'ailleurs il ya eu l'organisation d'un
référendum qui a vu la population de
crime est donc organisée par moscou
alors faire un homme la population de
crime et a accepté là aussi je pense à
une majorité assez écrasante de revenir
dans le giron de moscou ce référendum
n'est pas reconnu par la plupart des
pays sur la scène internationale
il est considéré comme illégitime voire
illégales les pays occidentaux parce
qu'elle était faite par le pays avec sa
non le pays voilà avec en plus
la présence de forces militaires du pays
canex donc ce serait un peu un
référendum avec un fusil sur la tempe
avant de les jeter
il faut pas se tromper voilà c'est fait
pour qui tu veux mais tu te trompes pas
de
puits laissions si on essaie de déplier
un petit peu ce qui s'est passé dans les
derniers jours
initialement quand le conflit là été
portée à l'attention des gens qui
portent pas une attention particulière
aux âges et aux politiques européennes
il y avait des
des
pourparlers qui semble être
mis de l'avant le pti que ce soit avec
emmanuel macron ou byron qui était
supposée parler à poutine avant que tout
ça arrive qu est-ce qui en est arrivé de
ces pourparlers l'ofppt quel était leur
objectif
bon pas là il faut revenir quelques
semaines voire quelques mois en arrière
peut-être tourner en 2021 2022 donc il
ya quelques mois
moscou vladimir poutine a décidé de
masse et un grand nombre de troupes à la
frontière ou aux frontières devrait-on
dire avec l'ukraine
on l'a les américains ont évoqué jusqu'à
150 voire 190000 troupes russes massés à
la frontière ce qui a en fait par
rapport aux conflits actuels
allumer tous les signaux d'alarmé
puisque aux yeux des américains et des
occidentaux 7 ce mouvement de troupes
étaient annonciateurs de quelque chose
de négatif alors pendant un long moment
les russes ont dit écoutez un on a le
droit de déployer des troupes sur notre
territoire c'est notre choix était à la
rigueur on fait ce qu'on veut avec notre
territoire aux mains de la place on les
envoie où on veut nos soldats à donne
juste que c'est sous le bois de france
dames et sa fureur voilà cela est deux
on fait ça pour mener des exercices
militaires donc n'imaginais pas quand on
est là pour
d'effets néfastes ou funestes et 3
ensuite il a évoqué le fait et ça il le
présente ainsi notamment la population
russe que selon lui il y avait une
menace qui provenait du cren la semaine
dernière qu'il l'a annoncé
l'opération militaire russe qu'il
qualifiait à l'époque de limites et il
l'a dit à la population russe parce que
l'ukraine ne représente une menace
non seulement parce qu'elle est dirigée
par des toxicomanes et des néo nazis at
il à t-il dit mais aussi parce que selon
lui l'ukraine menacé d'acquérir l'armé
nucléaire pour éventuellement attaqué la
russie lorsque ce qu'il faut
absolument éhontée
et donc pendant toute cette période où
la communauté internationale occidentaux
en tête à observer ces mouvements de
troupes on a essayé d'engager la
discussion avec vladimir poutine mais
c'était très difficile parce que d'une
part manifestement imandt et sur les
raisons sur les raisons et de il n'avait
pas envie d'arriver à une négociation et
c'est pas faute d'avoir essayé de la
part des occidentaux tu évoques emmanuel
macron qui a eu des discussions voilà
direct avec poutine le chancelier
allemand olaf schulze a été également à
moscou pour essayer d'arriver un terrain
d'entente on peut penser aussi au
ministre russe sergueï lavrov
lavrov des affaires étrangères qui a
rencontré très souvent son homologue
américain anthony blinken le président
byden des états unis et vladimir poutine
se sont parlé au téléphone avant le
début des hostilités pour essayer
d'arriver à une entente et on aurait pu
imaginer donc si la préoccupation de
poutine c'était cette question de
sécurité
et la perspective de voir l'ukraine jour
adhérer à l'otan et à l'union européenne
on pouvait trouver ça aurait pu être
réglé oui par des discussions oui alors
ça va demander beaucoup de travail de
l'imagination parce que l'ukraine en
tant qu'etat souverain
le droit de décider de quelle
organisation internationale elle veut ou
à la spire un jour à rejoindre c'est
vrai que c'est inscrit dans la
constitution ukrainienne qu'un jour le
pays devra adhérer à l'otan et à l'union
européenne mais encore une fois si
c'était juste cette question de sécurité
ou de même d'aspiration de l'ukraine sur
la scène internationale mais on aurait
pu trouver une solution dans le temps ce
mois les diplomates sont très bons pour
avoir des formules qui ont l'air un peu
obscur ou qui ne veut rien dire mais qui
satisfont tout le monde et on aurait pu
imaginer ça
déclare maillot chose oui évidemment il
ya clairement autre chose qui touche et
qui est beaucoup plus grave et qui
touchent donc on lisait cette idée a
priori que poutine ni la légitimité même
de l'existence de l'ukraine est la
nation ukrainienne et 2 il a
manifestement très peur que cette
démocratisation de l'ukraine puisse
donner des idées aux frères eurent qui
pourrait se faire aspirer à la même
chose
fait que les les russes le long des
jours 4 sur 5 à peu près dans la nuit
là-bas mais les relances l'attaquent de
ce que je lisais corrigez moi si je me
trompe s'attendent à un accueil plus ou
moins proche chaleureux mais au moins
d'avoir des gens de leur côté en arrive
en ukraine puis on se rend compte qu'ils
c'est pas du tout le cup et qui frappe
une résistance vraiment plus grande que
ce qu'ils s'attendaient oui et c'est là
probablement qu'il a fait une erreur
poutine en sous-estimant la
détermination de la population
ukrainienne a résisté et en
sous-estimant la capacité du président
ukrainien en ligne ce qui a inspiré
cette résistance est devenu du jour au
lendemain une super star des médias
sociaux oui oui qui était un comique un
acteur ou un humoriste et qui est devenu
un héros de la résistance
généralement et d'ailleurs on a parlé il
ya quelques mois d'afghanistan le
comportement des présidents dans les
dégâts est radicalement différent le
président afghan avait fui façon ali ben
là on a un président ukrainien qui a
décidé de mener d'inspirer la résistance
donc ça montre qu'il ya une nation
ukrainienne qui est prêt à se battre et
qui est prêt à opposer aux prix
évidemment de pertes civiles
potentiellement colossal une résistance
majeure poutine avait manifestement
penser que en lançant une attaque tous
azimuts sur l'ukraine il pourrait créer
une forme de choc des froids dans la
population ukrainienne et chez les
décideurs ukrainien qui aurait capitulé
devant la menace ou cette puissance
russe
considérable et tant que poutine ne
gagne pas hyper way et avec tous les
risques d' escalade que cela représente
et c'est pour ça que bon au moment où on
se parle alors on se parle il y à des
discussions entre une délégation
ukrainienne et russes en biélorussie je
serais très surpris que ça débouche sur
quelque chose parce que on est dans une
dynamique à l'heure actuelle du rapport
de force où on voit mal ce que poutine
pourrait proposer à zielinski que celui
ci pour accepter parce que si poutine
dit moi je veux des nazifié l'ukraine
donc ils voudraient décapité le
gouvernement ukrainien et dégager le
président azzedine ski d'ukraine lui
aujourd'hui il va pas dire oui je vais
partir il est pas dans une position
surtout qu'il a et l'appui de sa
population et l'appui
inespérée il ya encore une semaine de la
communauté
international les occidentaux en
particulier
s'il semblait quand même avoir une
espèce de sentiment de
1,1 genre de sentiment de déception de
la porte des ukrainiens ne pas avoir un
support plus marqué d d d autres pays à
l'international ouais alors au début je
pense notamment le président le
président céline ce qui au début a dit
vous savez on est seul et vous nous
laissez voilà face à la puissance
militaire russe nous faire nous faire
massacrer
c'est en ce sens que pour les ukrainiens
c'est une véritable tragédie mais au
sens le plus littéral du terme
il ya quelque chose d'évident parce que
on est dense on revient à la logique de
la guerre froide c'est à dire que vous
avez des acteurs qui sont dotés de
l'armé nucléaire la russie les états
unis et l'otan le principe de la guerre
froide allaient rester froide parce que
pour résumer et caricaturer la
dissuasion nucléaire a fait en sorte que
américains et russes ne se sont jamais
affrontées directement sur un théâtre
d'opérations donc si vous avez ça en
tête et vladimir poutine a quand même
rappelé de façon plus ou moins clair que
la russie avait l'armé nucléaire il
sous-tend qui seraient prêts à
l'utiliser donc par rapport à ça les
américains en premier lieu et tous les
pays membres de l'otan ne peuvent pas
envoyer de militaires combattre aux
côtés des ukrainiens sur le territoire
ukrainien mais ce qu'ils ont fait est là
ça encore une fois la résistance
ukrainienne
l'inspiration le comportement de deux
hélices qui a contribué au fait que les
occidentaux ont décidé
et là ça évolue à une vitesse assez
remarquable non seulement d'imposer des
sanctions économiques
d'une ampleur inégalée et qui vont
peut-être pas changer la dynamique à
court terme mais qui vont faire payer un
coup terrible ou potentiellement
terrible à la rue hier matière
économique de ce conflit là des
sanctions diplomatiques des
dénonciations qui font que la russie
aujourd'hui est un état paria va être
mis au ban de la communauté
internationale
et ont décidé d'envoyer des armes et il
ya des choses assez fascinante des pays
comme la suède comme l'allemagne qui
historiquement pour des raisons
évidentes dans le cas de l'allemagne
pour des raisons de posture neutre dans
le cas de la suède mais juste qu'avec
quelques jours refusé d'envoyer des
armes à l'ukraine 1 il ya une dizaine de
jours lorsque et les hollandais et les
britanniques ont voulu envoyer de
l'armement offensif en ukraine notamment
des missiles antichars ou des missiles
anti aériens à les transports devaient
éviter le territoire allemand par
exemple les avions pouvaient pas
survoler l'espace aérien allemand parce
qu'elle l'allemagne étaient opposées et
l'allemagne a décidé non seulement
d'augmenter son budget militaire mais
d'envoyer des armements offensifs
en ukraine y est l'europe en tant
qu'entité a décidé au cours du week-end
de financer l'achat et la livraison
d'armements même des avions de combat à
l'ukraine donc là on est dans quelque
chose là c'est pourquoi est-ce que ce
s'est pas vu par poutine comme indirects
alors que si les soldats samedi c'est
une excellent parce qu'au final c'est un
support assez clair la situation oui oui
c'est une excellente question ça
ressemble un peu à toutes proportions
gardées à ce qui s'est fait justement en
afghanistan suite à l'invasion de
l'union soviétique en 1979 on se
souvient que les américaines notamment
utilisé des groupes après bon ce soir
tournait un peu contre eux en les armant
en les formant et là aussi il utilisait
des armes américaines notamment les
fameux missiles stinger pour frapper un
des rues des corps des soldats
soviétiques pardon à c'est là exactement
la même chose voilà qui se fait là
si poutine a le sentiment de pernes il
risque d'augmenter la température
d'ailleurs il a fait le week-end en
mettant de l'avant cette idée que les
forces nucléaires sont prêtes
malgré ce que excuse moi je te promets
la menace nucléaire est ce que c'est
vraiment quelque chose que au 21e siècle
on peut s'imaginer que
une avenue possible c est ce que c'est
une menace qui qu'il en sait un peu
comme ça dans les annales les armes
nucléaires ou vraiment une possibilité
que qu'une tragique comme ce
alors peut-être un élément avant de
répondre directement à il faut savoir
que les armes nucléaires par définition
elles sont toujours prêtes à l'emploi
c'est pas des armes comme celle-là
centre est elle là ils sont
sortis de leurs lors qu'elles sont pas
dans un placard dans une réserve sont
prêtes il va demander à amira est louée
par définition ces armes là tous les
pays qui en disposent
elles sont prêtes à l'emploi avec un
préavis un très très court c'est ce qui
fait l'essence même de la dissuasion
nucléaire donc ça c'est premièrement
deuxième élément a
normalement lorsqu'on connaît les
répercussions potentielles de l' usage
de cette arme la
catastrophique d'accord les armes
actuelle on estime qu'elles seront
jusqu'à mille fois plus puissante que
les baumes qui ont été larguées sur
hiroshima et nagasaki en août 1945
deux cent mille morts donc personne ne
veut pratiquement la fin de l'humanité
avec les jours ma climatique accéléré
puis tout ce que ça plein jean-louis
alors là pour le coup on n'aurait même
pas attendre les effets à long terme des
changements climatiques pour une
extinction de la race humaine parce que
le risque évidemment c'est que si un
pays qui a l'armé nucléaire lance
une attaque nucléaire mais par
définition les autres pays doivent
répliqué à ça donc là on est dans
l'escaladé le scénario
apocalyptique alors lorsque poutine dit
vous savez moi je mets en état d' alerte
où je le dois pas très loin du bouton il
joue du théâtre
est-ce qu'il est encore rationnelle à
des questions c'est en sais pas c'était
la légation en fait parce que
aucun aucun aucun leader rationnel on va
jamais passé qui vous qui va mettre ses
menaces à exécution mais les si on on
peut présupposer que peut-être perdu la
boule le sait plus la même
situation c'est plus du tout la même
situation et c'est ce qui fait qu est ce
qui se passe en ce moment est imminent
grave pour les ukrainiens mais sur la
scène internationale et ça donne
vraiment le vertige parce que on revient
à une époque convoyer révolue on voir
naître un monde ancien celui de la
guerre froide qui grosso modo de la fin
de la deuxième guerre mondiale jusqu'à
1991 voyez en permanence cette épée de
damoclès sur la tête de tout le monde
mais on s'en est bien sorti encore une
fois puisqu'elle allait rester froide on
peut faire le parallèle avec ce qui
s'est passé avec la crise lors de la
crise de cuba en octobre
1962 qui est probablement pendant la
guerre froide des historiennes la guerre
froide irait chercher d'autres exemples
complémentaires mais disons que la crise
de cuba en octobre 62 c'est le moment où
elle est passée le plus près dans l'
affrontement nucléaire entre les états
unis et l'urss
on est peut-être à assat aujourd'hui
parce qu'encore une fois on ne peut plus
présumé de la rationalité de poutine ça
veut pas dire qu'il va l'utiliser mais
vu son comportement sur l'ukraine
on va on doit considérer
malheureusement cette possibilité là et
c'est pour ça qu'il y à cette
mobilisation internationale il faut
trouver oui un moyen de dd la résistance
ukrainienne mais aussi
de trouver une porte de sortie et on
marche à des heures parce qu'on veut pas
trop froisser non plus foot c'est
justement à cause de cette raison voilà
il faut pas le pousser dans ses
retranchements où ils deviennent
complètement parano pitt seul
alors il
l'usagé de l'armé nucléaire c'est
toujours un petit peu plus compliqué
qu'appuyer sur un simple bouton ans
massa le gars puissent émerger un peu le
bouton on l'avait beaucoup évoqué sa aux
états unis lorsque trump ou s'il était
président et des fois il y avait pas
très bien puis on imaginer qu'il pouvait
balancer des armes est clair c'est pas
lui qui va aller poser sous le temps
aussi il y donne l'orne ces gens là
donne l'ordre mais après il faut
l'exécuter mais
là il faut imaginer que dans l'entourage
de vladimir poutine dans l'appareil
militaire russe ou bureaucratiques russe
il ya des gens qui disent nous on
partage pas la même vision que vous
monsieur le président poutine parce que
vous avez complètement
perdu la boule vous êtes déconnecté de
la réalité donc on va pas mettre à
exécution ce tournoi mais ça fait
beaucoup de si ouais c'est ça mais
j'imagine que
le support pour vladimir poutine dans
les derniers la dernière semaine en
russie
jack mis à rude épreuve quand même là
parce que en voyant le premièrement la
résistance ukrainienne en voyant le
l'inutilité de cette guerre là j'imagine
qu'il ya eu des des gens qui ont dû
lever le bras le même si la boj imagine
sur lève le bras du tram ans en prison
mais je peux pas croire que
les hauts placés russe répond oui
systématiquement à tous les amis sont
forcés de le faire pour l'instant
j'imagine vihear dans un régime autorise
auront à savoir s'il ya du monde qui se
pose parce que ça sera pas jusqu'à nous
voilà dans un régime autoritaire
dictatorial comme celui que poutine a
mis en place en plus soumis c'est
manifestement énormément isolé 1 c'est
difficile de savoir qui s'exprime et 2c
de c'est difficile de savoir si ces gens
s'expriment est ce qu'ils ont vraiment
en effet où est-ce qu'ils ont la
capacité de de neutraliser par exemple
poutine mais il est évident que le fait
que l'opération se déroule mal qu' il y
ait une résistance ukrainienne qu'il y
ait une mobilisation internationale
qu'il y ait aussi en russie une
mobilisation populaire tu l'as dit un
manifesté contre le pouvoir russe s'est
pas passé trois semaines dans un spa sur
la rue wellington ottawa
y en a quand même
c'est assez difficile de connaître
l'état réel de l'opinion publique russe
pas vraiment des sondages qu'on peut
considérer comme éminemment fiable mais
ce qu'on comprend c'est que les russes
qui ont accès à une information plus
objective que celles transmises par les
médias contrôlés par le gouvernement
donc à des fins de propagande
considère que cette guerre n'a pas lieu
d'être et que aller dangereuse est-ce qu
au sein de ces fameux groupe des
oligarques l'élite proches du pouvoir en
russie il ya des gens qui seraient prêts
à prendre des mesures je sais pas
lesquels pour écarter poutine du pouvoir
impossible de savoir c'est difficile de
savoir ça pourrait être une option de
sortie de crise mathématiques parce que
c'est ces oligarques la main qui paient
la facture de ce par les sanctions
économiques
oui et essayer de le but en des
sanctions et et économique lorsque par
exemple américain européenne visant à
créer un groupe pour identifier les
yachts les jets privés les maisons et
quasiment les saisir on ne tape sur ces
oligarques qui bénéficie depuis une
vingtaine d'années dans la mansuétude de
poutine et poutine les tient aussi par
ça entre autres des informations
compromettantes sur ceux ci mais ces
gens là avec les sanctions qui sont
encore une fois d'une ampleur qui paie
probablement pas anticipé ya encore une
semaine
e il faut aller taper au porte-monnaie
en espérant que ça suffise pour qu'ils
modifient le comportement de poutine
alors on l'entend 1
entre les branches qu' il y a des gens
en privé qu'ils sont contre la politique
de poutine c'est bien beau d'écrire un
texto à quelqu'un que vous connaissez
moi j'aime pas trop ce qui fait mais si
vous faites hargneuse et nous ça nous
avantage pas un an le terran le podcast
pour vous parler encore une fois de
hawke cioccio sont les partenaires du
sans fil du podcast heitz maths ça
devrait pas venir en option appeler
votre fournisseur internet puis avoir un
service à la clientèle de qualité
ça devrait pas être négligée puis
pourtant ça les potentiels ni c'est tout
le temps comme on le dit en discutant
compliqué qu'on appelle ça c'est
toujours compte des ces compagnies le
aux cures sont tellement afin d'en avoir
le goût d'appeler juste pour l'argent ça
va donner vos amis ou amants que son
fantôme action ce matin thomas clay
service est bon sérieusement vous serez
pas déçus par action vous allez appeler
votre ami votre ami max qui va être tout
le temps là pour vous à un bout d'appel
il va tout indisponibles ça va tout le
temps à être ultra facile à utiliser que
de promo sans filtre en un mot pour un
mois d'essai gratuit
un mois d'essai gratuit vous avez rien à
perdre littéralement rien à perdre puis
tout à gagner au maître mot gagner si
vous n'êtes pas un bon film ben c'est sa
rancune mais je pense que vous allez
loin au x6 au point c'est un
puits dans tous ceux y à l'espèce de
fantômes de la chine qui demeure dormant
et silencieux qu'est-ce qui en est de la
chine dans cette dans cette guerre et de
son positionnement
le positionnement de pékin est très
intéressant souvient qu'il ya quelques
semaines au début des jeux olympiques
d'hiver à pékin donc alexis genghini
vladimir poutine se sont rencontrés ont
publié un communiqué de l'union comme
aucune qu'on avait vu voilà une union
illimité indéfinie et tout ça on a pu on
peut interpréter cela comme une forme de
bhl en scène de pékin à moscou pour
mener son opération
militaire mais
je pense que les dirigeants chinois sont
assez malins pour
observer et tirer des leçons de ce qui
se passe et lorsque des sanctions
monétaires contre la russie ça peut
aussi signifier beaucoup d'argent oui
alors mettons pékin peut compenser en
partie ces sanctions la presse que la
chine est très très riche et peut par
exemple acheter du gaz ou du pétrole
russe que les européenne décide de ne
plus acheter pékin peut compenser à
court moyen terme les pertes aux russes
mais
il y avait et j'ai des étudiants qui
m'ont posé la question à
7 dans cet imaginaire on parle beaucoup
depuis quelques années de l'alliance
entre régimes autoritaires et que ces
régimes autoritaires seraient en train
de gagner sur les démocraties et qu'on
pense à cette alliance évidemment les
deux joueurs clés c'est poutine
exceeding poule dont j'avais des
étudiants qui me disait est ce que vous
pensez que si jean ping va profiter de
ce qui se passe en ukraine pour lancer
une opération militaire pour récupérer
taïwan parce que là aussi il ya cette
aspiration la des dirigeants chinois à
long terme je penserai pas parce que là
on serait dans un scénario vraiment
catastrophique là on pourrait faire la
comparaison avec le début de la deuxième
guerre mondiale sans aucun doute
je pense que j'ose croire que les
dirigeants chinois sont beaucoup plus
rationnelle plus raisonnable et
s'aperçoivent que finalement cette idée
démocratique les valeurs libérales qui
la sous tendent mais en dépit des
imperfections de la démocratie des
problèmes au sein des démocraties pis de
celles ci sont nombreux les gens veulent
se battre pour ça et quelque part c'est
ce qu'on peut retirer de positif de la
situation actuelle enfin c'est une leçon
essentielle à attirer et en ce sens le
combat que mènent les ukrainiens c'est
un combat pour l'ukraine mais c'est
probablement un combat pour tous les
pays et tous les gens qui sont
attaché à ses valeurs
libérales donc ça dépasse largement et
c'est ce qui fait que c'est un événement
qui probablement même plus marquant que
l'on septembre 2001
puis par rapport à cette relation la
russie et chine dans les médias j'ai
entendu beaucoup justement qui les cinq
5 années mais clair c'est très mal la
russie plus entendu aussi d'autres
observateurs dire que finalement c'était
quand même superficielle ces sanctions
le piquet de toute façon la russie
pouvait toujours se tourner vers la
chine fera traverser avec la chine qui
peut être continuer à avoir une économie
qui tu vois bien que l'europe allait pas
non plus coupé tous les ponts parce que
l'europe est aussi dépendant la russie
donc
lui pourrait perdre ainsi donc est ce
que est ce que finalement la russie et
pied lépi la chine puis l'asie en
général pourraient un peu se replier sur
eux mêmes devenir un petit peu tout au
tout suffisant puis quand même très bien
s'en sort c'est
à à court moyen terme on peut imaginer
encore une fois que le porte-monnaie
chinois permettent d'atténuer le coût
des sanctions contre la russie
s'ils décident week end vraiment venir
en aide à la russie et ils vont
probablement joué un jeu plus
attentistes vont voir ce qui se passe
ils vont peut-être dénoncé le
comportement des occidentaux on voit dix
ans pas bien utilisé le langage de la
guerre froide voilà vous attiser les
tensions mais
faut pas oublier que lorsque les deux
pays se disait communiste il ya eu un
schisme et on a pu l'exploiter notamment
lorsque le président américain nixon
était à pékin et à
extirper
la chine la zone d influence soviétique
pour aujourd'hui par les occidentaux il
faudrait peut-être faire ça songez à
faire ça sans être pour autant naïf
c'est à dire sans imaginer que comme on
a pu le faire au début des années 2000
dans les années 90 que l'économie de
marché en chine va se traduire par
l'instauration d'une démocratie
manifestement ce n'est pas le cas il ne
sera pas le cas mais il faudrait
peut-être atténuer les discours de
tension et qui était aussi très en vogue
entre les états unis la chine entre les
occidentaux la chine pour x raisons dont
la dernière est évidemment la pandémie
de covic 19 donc moins il faudrait
baisser la température dans les tensions
avec pékin pour montrer à pékin qu'elle
a beaucoup plus intérêt à accepter les
règles du jeu libéral de l'ordre
international que de s'arrimer un régime
qui de toute façon pour un avenir
prévisible va être mis au ban des
nations et les chinois sont quand même
assez sensible à cette question je crois
de
la réputation et par conséquent je les
vois mal jouer l'allié fidèle de poutine
qui est prêt à absolument tout faire
pour aider son régime
on est assez de plus en plus gênant
d'être à lille la russie en ce moment je
te ment par des accents comme ça oui et
il faudra que il ya une revue en ligne
qui s'appelle le grand continent qui
tient une carte de la réaction sur la
scène internationale des pays par
rapport à ce qui se passe en ukraine
dans les pays qui ont dénoncé les
pélicans ont soutenu les pays qui n'ont
pas condamné les pays qui ont pas pris
de position et on voit se dessiner cette
fameuse rivalité entre les démocraties
et les régimes un petit peu plus un peu
plus autoritaire est ce que ça veut dire
que cette rivalité doit se traduire par
une guerre
nécessairement je sais pas peut-être que
la guerre en ukraine c'est la première
guerre de cette époque là il voit
l'affrontement entre la démocratie et
les régimes autoritaires peut-être c'est
la guerre aussi qui fera en sorte qu'il
n'y ait pas cet affrontement acquis mais
pas la guerre
voilà alors dans l'histoire on l'a
souvent dit ça il faut faire une guerre
pour arrêter toutes les guerres la
première guerre mondiale ça devait être
la der des der
l'histoire ne marche pas très bien de
cet hiver mais gardons espoir et donc on
voit ces blocs là qu'ils peuvent
peut-être se mettre en place et ça va
obliger à réfléchir par exemple
le brésil n'a pas condamné
la chose les dirigeants brésiliens n'ont
pas condamné le truc donc ça doit
peut-être aussi guidé le type de
relation qu'on doit avoir à l'avenir
avec les dirigeants algériens n'ont pas
condamné les dirigeants saoudiens n'ont
pas condamné égyptien donc ça ça va tu
étais probablement les relations qu'ont
qu'on aura
ça veut pas dire qu'il faut rompre les
relations c'est à dire qu'il faudra
souvenir de cette carte de cette carte
là et
voilà peut-être pas être trop naïf dans
leurs relations avec certains pays à
l'avenir est ce que des pays qui ont
publiquement soutenu qu'ils soutiennent
publiquement la russie oui il ya le
pakistan le venezuela et cuba si je me
trompe pas ma mémoire visuelle de la
carte est encore bonne ce matin voilà
alors bon c'est pas non plus des pays
qui sont réputés pour leur leur bilan
démocratique et libéral à la pression
des alliés reste un des tauliers qui fit
mais je sais pas pour les autres pays
mais que buck qui profites tu profité
longtemps de cette alliance que oui
dynamique avec la wii c'est pareil pour
le venezuela le régime de maduro
ressemble furieusement au régime de
poutine dans le sens où c'est des
régimes qui accapare la richesse d'un
pays au détriment du bien-être général
de ce pays l'un des dirigeants qui sont
prêts finalement à faire de leur pays un
des pics du tiers-monde où quasiment un
des pays paria tant qu' ils continuent à
s'enrichir parce que il faut pas oublier
que le bilan de poutine en politique
intérieure il est quand même assez
catastrophique
l'économie russe oui les russes sont
riches parce qu'ils ont du pétrole et du
gaz et ça a pu moderniser leur arsenal
militaires par exemple mais les russes
je vois là il ya soit les très riches
soient des très pauvres l'économie
allait pas vraiment de diversifier les
russes aujourd'hui ils vont s'apercevoir
que leurs monnaies elle vaut strictement
plus rien qui aura peut-être des
difficultés d'approvisionnement dans les
supermarchés ils risquent de trouver ça
très dur la russie aussi un pays qui
voit son espérance de vie diminuer il ya
eu un million
le déficit démographique il est 2
millions de personnes en 2021 en russie
donc la population a diminué et ça c'est
au passif du bilan de poutine il a rien
fait au final pour le développement de
son pays qui voient là un très grand
pays qui pourrait être un pays
évidemment
extraordinaire mais depuis vingt ans il
est dirigé par des kleptomanes exactions
et avec des images étaient sortis de
comme les lits manoir de poutine reculé
d'un hors la piste était juste de
l'opulence même ce qui finalement à
l'opposé des fondements du communiste ce
qui était supposé être soit à la base
les lignes oui à rien poutine oui
poutine c'est pas une communiste à la
ligne ne vous met mal à staline ilan et
il en est très très loin lui il a juste
la nostalgie de la puissance et je pense
pas qu'il ait la nostalgie du régime
communiste il alla et de l'idéal
communiste de répartition égale des
richesses ah non lui la nostalgie de
cette puissance qui faisait que moscou
faisait peur sur la scène internationale
il a voulu à restaurer ça
mais c'est qu'ils particulier on parle
de poutine dit sa vision de la russie on
dirait que c'est juste une affaire
d'image pin affaire d'ego en fait
aucunement stratégie que je sais de
d'envahir les d'ukraine pour un peu
montré ça c'est sa force son drake et
rien d'autre que une guerre d'image de
prestige et d'égout oui oui et c'est ça
qui est très troublant parce que encore
une fois comment disait tout à l'heure
si l'objectif de poutine était
simplement de restaurer le prestige du
pays et quand les prennent avec sérieux
et restaurer une zone d influence ou
assurer une zone d influence autour de
son pays mais il savait très bien le
faire il avait le plan de match parfait
très bien fonctionné je disais tout à
l'heure la georgie en 2008 l'ukraine en
2014 ces pays là tant que vous avez des
provinces séparatistes soutenus par
moscou qui déstabilisent ces pays là
donc qui crée une forme de conflit
territorial goossens et pays ces pays ne
peuvent pas intégrer l'union européenne
ou l'otan peuvent pas donc ça
fonctionnait très bien son histoire et
voilà pour une raison encore une fois
qui fait qu'on peut pas nécessairement
un peu plus nécessairement estimé que
poutine est quelqu'un de brillant et de
rationnel et de génial
il a opté pour un truc
qui est un changement de style de jeu
qui va lui mais qui nous met dans une
situation particulièrement dangereuse et
qui au final à lui risque de lui coûter
lui coûter très très cher parce que si
vous voulez par exemple empêcher avec
son intervention militaire que l'ukraine
est d allier intègre un jour l'otan
l'union européenne en fait il fait juste
qu'il va accélérer il a juste accéléré
sans il ya quand même des pays européens
la pologne parmi les premiers comme on
dit il faut dès à présent lancer le
processus d'adhésion de l'ukraine à
l'union européenne et en plus on les
occidentaux on devra moralement ça aux
ukrainiens comme dans les années 90 on a
élargi de l'otan aux anciens pays
d'europe centrale et orientale qui
étaient sous la domination soviétique on
l'a pas fait pour menacer moscou parce
qu'il ya eu des formats autant plus
russie même les américains dont jour
envisager que la russie fasse partie de
l'otan bon il ya eu des promesses n'ont
pas été tenues pour x ou y
x et y raison mais l'élargissement de
l'otan il s'est pas fait uniquement dans
une perspective
d'occidentaux qui voulaient menacée
la russie il s'est fait cet
élargissement pour des raisons morales
historique ces pays d'europe centrale et
orientale qui étaient sous influence
russe pendant soviétique pendant la
guerre froide on les a laissés tomber je
pense en particulier à la pologne
edmond leur devait de les intégrer et
dans l'union européenne et dans l'otan
parce qu'on les avait abandonnés pendant
des décennies
et eux avaient besoin de cette garantie
de sécurité donc une crème
plus tôt que tard
tant et si bien qu'on va voir comment
elle s'en sort là à des rats c'est c'est
évident un ara à l'union européenne et à
l'otan il faut faire comprendre à le
faire accepter par le dirigeant qui sera
je comprends bien aussi le temps une des
clauses principales finalement le set de
cet accord le sait que si un des pays le
temps et est attaqué tous les pays de
l'otan doivent mener à sa défense oui
c'est le fameux article 5 donc j'imagine
que c'est l'artiste qui dérange le plus
poutine parce que justement d'un code
unique rennes qui fait partie de l'otan
bay ont pu venir chercher des parties
territoire outils avoir une main sur ces
pilules oui alors théoriquement ça peut
être l'article qui illustre la puissance
de l'organisation
c'est une solidarité alors il faut
préciser que cette solidarité elle est
pas automatique
l'article 5 ne dit pas si un pays est
attaqué vous devez tous automatiquement
venir à notre aide non non il faut que
les pays membres décident
décide pas automatique
et donc ce qu'on pouvait imaginer être
un article de qui relève le révèle la
puissance de l'alliance c'est aussi un
article qui créent une vulnérabilité
énorme au sein de l'alliance parce que
il ya des pays j'ai évoqué les anciens
pays d'europe centrale et orientale
quant à intégrer l'otan en cours des
dernières années des dernières décennies
garantit pas que on serait prêt à aller
se battre pour les défend du baryum les
états baltes oui on est ok tout à
l'heure estonie lituanie lettonie
je pas certaine que les décideurs
allemands britanniques français
canadiens et américains 6 et a attaqué
frontalement dirait automatiquement on
va allez vous soutenir il ya l'un des
derniers pays qui a intégré de l'otan
c'est si je dis pas de bêtises à la
république de macédoine du nord
et ont pris les armes pour la macédoine
mois qui restent bat pour la macédoine
du nord honnêtement à et donc poutine
savez très bien ça et j'espère et je
pense que il a aussi l'a fait cette
erreur de calcul vis-à-vis des
occidentaux il s'imaginer que
du fait de cette solidarité qui est
probablement très fragile qui
apparaissait il ya encore une semaine
très fragile mais il n'y aurait pas une
unité dans la réaction et une
coordination et une solidarité aussi
grande que celle que l'on voit
maintenant
alors c'est la dynamique des conflits
c'est la guerre qui
impose ce type de réaction qui était
probablement
prévisible ou inattendus
dans cet article finalement il y est
beau sur papier mais au final il ya
aucune
aucune vraie emprise la forrest et que
au final où est l'otan reste une entité
politique dont les décisions sont prises
par des acteurs politiques qui peuvent
avoir des calculs et des intérêts
divergents mais c'est ce qui fait aussi
l'importance de l'alliance qui est
fascinant cet article là au final parce
que et on se souvient que lorsque le
président trump est arrivé au pouvoir il
a rechigné à reconnaître que les états
unis interviendrait en vertu de
l'article 5 6 1 jour et alors tout le
monde au sein de l'alliance disais ça y
est les etats-unis peu plus leur faire
confiance à la chancelière allemande
angela merkel avait dit on peut plus
compter sur
le président français manuel macro et
dit l'auteur est en état de mort
cérébrale il ya quelques années enfin si
vieux on imaginait que l'otan servait
plus à rien aujourd'hui
voilà l'otan
oui oui et vladimir poutine a non
seulement renforcer l'otan il à
renforcer l'union européenne à son corps
défendant bien entendu c'est ce qu'ils
voulaient faire mais ça cet article 5
kills extraordinaire parce que en même
temps c'est un signe de solidarité
remarquable
la seule fois où il a été évoqué ça a
été après le 11 septembre 2001 par des
pays européens qu'on dit les états unis
vous avez et attaquer donc on va évoquer
l'article 5 pour venir vous aider les
américains ont dit non non c'est
gentiment on est arrivé voilà on va se
débrouiller tout seul surtout que vous
nous aviez un peu embêté auparavant
et en maintenance et sa vulnérabilité
parce que comme je disais c'est pas
automatique et peut-être que si des pays
sont attaqués on n'irait pas
nécessairement les errements les défauts
qu'est ce qui se passe avec les états
unis qui sont somme toute quand même
silencieux depuis le début de tout c'est
ce que ce n'est que pour essayer de
réduire les tensions avec la russie pays
d'éviter un conflit plus grand parce que
pour une force mondiale comme les états
unis de
symptômes qu'on n'entende pas parler
ceux qui sont une décision clairement et
reese les etats-unis jouent pas un rôle
de leadership 1-1 très très fort là
dedans alors on a vu ce week-end par
exemple que le président byden étaient
gelés dans le delaware et il a refusé
de réagir lorsque poutine a laissé
entendre que les forces nucléaires
étaient en état c'est manifestement
voulu c'est pas pour ça que dans la
surenchère et risquent les calades
escalade verbale par contre ce que
l'administration by dane a très bien
fait depuis des semaines maintenant 1
ces communiqués sur le sérieux de la
menace on se fiait a encore quelques
jours lorsque maiden ou des
représentants de son administration dea
vous savez on a des infos qui nous
montrent que ce que fait poutine avec
les troupes là la frontière l'ukraine
c'est pas juste pour sentir se dégourdir
les jambes c'est il prépare une
offensive potentiellement de grand
nombre il avait raison le renseignement
américain avait raison on les a souvent
critiqué pour rater des choses pour dire
des bêtises pour pas voir des des
phénomènes que ce soit l'irak en 2003 où
l'on 70 en 2001 donc il communique très
bien sûr sur la menace et il est parvenu
joe biden et son administration a créé
un front commun occidental ce qui
n'était pas nécessairement évident un
parce qu'il ya eu la présidence de trump
keim mines et la bonne entente entre les
pays membres de l'otan entre les pays
entre les etats unis aussi et les pays
européens entre les etats-unis et le
canada
hebeisen a réussi il faut lui donner
crédit à lui puis tous les autres à
voile à être à la hauteur de l'événement
et a imposé par exemple des sanctions et
un message un message commun maintenant
il va falloir voir comment on joue il
joue la carte de la désescalade lorsque
la fenêtre d'opportunité se présente on
disait là il ya en ce moment il ya des
discussions entre l'ukrainien et russes
en miel russie tant mieux si elle
débouche piqué on s'aperçoit à la fois
juste rendre compte que c'est bon ça
tant mieux tant mieux
mais c'est peut-être pas le meilleur
moment la dynamique elle est peut-être
pas propice à une entente mais il va
falloir un moment de trouver un moyen
est ce que c'est
parce que je vois mal mais ton avec tout
ce qu'on dit [ __ ] tôt je vois mal
comment
poutine pourrait
reculer de ses positions une fois aussi
avancé le est-ce que la solution ce
serait le laisser une porte de sortie
oui il faut trouver sa dalle tout le
défi c'est de trouver à une porte de
sortie qui satisfasse tout le monde
ouais
qui n'humilie personnes ouais c'est ça
ah parce que l'humiliation dans
l'histoire des relations internationales
mais bon c'est jamais très bon on se
souvient de la première guerre mondiale
le traité de versailles qui est vécu
comme une humiliation par les allemands
et ça permet à hitler d'arrivée et puis
on connaît la suite donc humilié sais
c'est pas très bon il faut trouver une
porte de sortie
si on estime par exemple que poutine ne
peut pas être délogés pouvoir on peut
espérer mais voilà on fait le calcul qui
pourra pas il faut trouver un moyen pour
que lui disent écoutez c'est moi le
raisonnable là dedans ah je m'aperçois
que
ça fonctionne ça fonctionne pas il
faudra pas qu'il dise comme ça
évidemment mais je prends sur moi pour
le bien-être de tout le monde de revenir
à quelque chose d'avant mais est-ce
qu'on peut revenir à la situation qui
prévalait avant
il peut pas demander par exemple que
céline skip ouais voilà je peux
aujourd'hui zielinski kir et lui dire
écoute ça serait bien après tout ce que
tu as fait depuis cinq jours que tu
partes je ne vois pas quelqu'un qui
règne lui dire ça est-ce qu'on pourrait
revenir à ces fameuses accord de minsk
qui sont sensés qui était censé régler
la situation qui avait émergé suite à
l'intervention de 2014 notamment pour
régler le problème donc de ces régions
de l'est de l'ukraine où il ya des
mouvements séparatistes pro-russes il ya
13 points je pense dans les accords
de minsk il ya des divergences entre
craignent un séparatiste ukrainien pro
russe russe sur l'interprétation et le
séquençage de la mise en application de
ces accords là à l'heure actuelle c'est
le seul truc sur lequel concret sur
lequel on peut on peut retomber
c'était le prétexte au départ de dire on
de quelques poutres
considérer la légitimité de ces régions
le hope i ii
du fait qu'ils voulaient se séparer pour
rejoindre la russie on pourrait dire et
beaucoup de monde soit content mais on a
un ex six régions le à la russie que de
toute façon sont majoritairement
séparatiste tout le monde est content
puis on rentre chez nous on rentre chez
soi ouais ouais alors est-ce qu'on
accepterait en vertu du principe de
l'inviolabilité des frontières
aucun principe central des relations
internationales et qui clés en europe
quand redécoupe le territoire de
l'ukraine qu'on l'amputé un petit peu de
cette région là je sais pas ça serait
spectaculaire
en même temps le redécoupage des
frontières d'un pays ça c'est faire
l'europe dans les années 90 en
ex-yougoslavie l'implosion de l'ex
yougoslavie a donné naissance à des pays
qui n'existait pas avant donc
est ce qu'on pourrait imaginer sa
salade l'imagination au pouvoir
aujourd'hui pourquoi pas alors est ce
que les ukrainiens ça va être tout à
fait enclin à ça
parce qu'il faut pas oublier et c'est
pour ça qu'ils ont imaginé il ya encore
une semaine lorsque poutine a dit moi je
reconnais c'est république séparatiste
du donbass et du losc
donc j'en vois du coût des forces nous
maintienne la paix pour les protéger
contre les exactions le craignait là
aussi fictive enfin moi
ces mouvements séparatistes qui
contrôlent à peu près un tiers de ces
régions moscou enfin poutine lorsqu'il
parlait avait précisé qu'elle lui
concédait la totalité de ces régions
administratives que donc deux tiers de
plus qu'il fallait aller chercher sauf
que là les ukrainiennes sont
majoritaires ils sont un pied et
contrôle
donc il faudrait définir
les frontières
j'imagine mal les ukrainiens un indien
sur le deux tiers ou depuis 2014 on a le
contrôle et puis la ligne de front on va
pas la déplacer alors qu'elle n'a pas
bougé
il
faudra négocier
dans la partie la plus probable femme un
peu probable mais
la guerre à l'accélère énormément les
choses voilà et c'est pas impossible
j'ai pas que c'est probable mais je vous
dis pas que c'est impossible que des
bouts de territoire ukrainien
espace et en plus ça pourrait être très
intéressant d'ailleurs puis on est un
peu dans l'anticipation dans
l'imagination
parce que je vous disais tout à l'heure
tant qu'un pays est pris avec un conflit
sur son territoire il peut pas intégrer
l'otan l'union européenne
si vous enlevez ce territoire qui vous
posent problème
c'est l'un des frères thomas oui oui et
c'est pour ça que
c'est quasiment incompréhensible que
poutine est pas garder son plan de match
qui fonctionnait très bien parce que en
gardant le statu quo qui était celui de
puis 2014 l'ukraine ne pouvait pas
entrer dans l'union européenne entend et
tout le monde était content
il ya dix jours tous les européens vous
arriver mais non ils rentreront jamais
on va pas les empêcher d'aspirer à jour
éventuellement peut-être faire acte de
candidature si les conditions le
permettent
vous voyez le truc
aujourd'hui ils sont plus proches et oui
alors si on s'y se débarrasser de poids
mort finalement qu'ils n'aiment pas là
il pourrait encore y sera encore plus
proche de la lésion non écoute il ne
serait peut-être pas nécessairement
d'accord avec ça
qu'est-ce-qui qu'est-ce que ça prendrait
pour que poutine soit délogé du pouvoir
ça prendrait un coup d'état de l'armée
russe faudrait qu'il y ait des chefs de
l'armée dont ils ont reconnu les
autorités de stockholm ouais il faudrait
aussi que cette fameuse élites
économiques là ces fameux oligarques
et le courage de dire écoute non
seulement ce que tu fais c'est
moralement abject c'est politiquement
idiot
c'est toute une ruine casser toutes ces
choses le sais parce que c'est tout ça
et tu nous empêche qui nous empêche
potentiellement d'aller passer l'été sur
la côte d'azur en france ouais les rangs
modèle pitt touche pas à mes vacances
non mais c'est vrai qu'on en rigole mais
le sens des sanctions c'est ça ouais et
est ce que ces gens là peuvent avoir le
courage de dire à poutine bon écoute
dignement voilà est-ce que la rue russe
l'opinion publique russe va continuer à
se mobiliser
contre lui il faudrait qu'ils aient
comme un
une coalition d'acteurs l'alarmé les
forces de sécurité et les élites
économiques
la population qui arrive
[Musique]
à mêler un putsch alors il faut espérer
qu'il soit pas violents ce putsch là
parce que hein il semblerait qu'il
admire poutine était traumatisée par la
fin de mouammar kadhafi en libye
voilà qui en 2011 a été bon a battu de
façon assez sordide dans la rue et
d'après ce qu'on entend c'est quelque
chose qu'il aurait énormément marqué
donc si lui s'imagine subir sort pareil
ça peut le pousser à faire plein de
bêtises il est d'ici là et a très mal
réagir ou à vouloir se protéger donc il
faudrait lui trouver une porte de sortie
un exil dans sa datcha à voir
un exil doré peut-être je sais pas mais
après il
est actuellement responsable des crimes
de guerre qui pourrait lui valoir
éventuellement des poursuites sur la
scène internationale mais ce qui cette
évasion dans ce moment c'est considérer
internet comme un clin d'oeil à abel
lorsque là je pense dans la nuit de
dimanche à lundi dans la seconde ville
notamment d'ukraine dont je serai jamais
prononcer le nom là car qui vous choque
tant pis je m'excuse auprès des
locuteurs et deux ukrainiens pour
on a assez documenté un que les russes
ont tiré notamment des batteries de
missiles sur des installations civiles
à faire usage du missile qui a pas
explosé au milieu d'un quartier
résidentiel
oui ça aussi c'est une preuve que
contrairement à ce que disent les russes
et porte parole militaire par exemple on
ne cible que des infrastructures
militaires
c'est pas vrai et le fait qu'il touche
aussi des civils c'est probablement ce
qui peut arriver
plus de la situation va être difficile
c'est à dire que s'il n'arrive pas comme
c'est le cas à prendre le contrôle comme
ça du pays en maintenant quelques
frappes ciblées qui ne sont destinés à
faire peur à démoraliser ils peuvent
passer à une étape supérieure parce
qu'ils n'ont pas encore utilisé toute
leur puissance militaire a pas l'oublier
et donc ils peuvent dire on va cibler
délibérément la population pour casser
la volonté de résister de la population
faut se souvenir ce qu'ont fait les
russes en tchétchénie au début des
années 2000 un bon allez voir des images
là de grozny entre kroes 1996 au regard
des grosses ni 2001
ils ont quasiment rasé grosse
mouche capable où ils ont la puissance
militaire de le faire ils ont peut-être
la doctrine aussi militaires de le faire
est ce qu'ils peuvent se permettre de le
faire alors que toute la communauté
internationale regarde
c'est ça la face et ce soir c'est un
joli dos
arrive qu'un conte ni portes - attention
maintenant toutes les yeux du monde sont
rivés sur lui sur l'écran justement
l'impression la russie aussi marche sur
des oeufs dans un sens parce que s'ils
vont trop
férocement dans leurs attaques et les
sanctions est encore plus plus forte et
pillé puis ils pourront pas revenir
dessus après oui tout à fait c'est
probablement d'ailleurs pour ça et en
ayant conscience de ça que
le plan militaire initiale était quand
même d'une attaque assez limité au sens
des cibles pas limité au niveau du
territoire encore une fois
ils ont quand même décidé d'attaquer
l'ukraine coût complet pas simplement de
faire des opérations militaires dans les
régions contestées de l'ess avec pour
objectif de prendre la capitale et de
dégager le gouvernement pour mettre un
gouvernement à la solde de moscou bon
mais pour faire ça et qu'elle la
population entre guillemets et craignent
elles acceptent entre guillemets il
fallait le faire en tuant le moins de
personnes possible et avalant le plus
vite possible
sauf que là c'est ça on voit que ça
ça fonctionne pas et le coup aussi
humaine pour la russie peut augmenter
aujourd'hui sa première fois qu'ils
reconnaissent avoir eu des morts qu'on
sépare le nombre de morts sur les
réseaux sociaux il ya eu des chiffres
qui circulent bon je vais pas les citer
parce que je n'ai pas de vérification
mais ça peut aussi ça va se retourner
contre vladimir poutine s'il ya de plus
en plus de cercueils de soldats qui pour
certains semble-t-il ont été envoyées là
sans même savoir qu'ils allaient faire
la guerre
puis on leur disait vous allez combattre
des nazis ce qu'ils veulent mais ils
commettent des nazis alors qu'ils
combattent
le fait que ce soit
le premier conflit de cette ampleur le à
l'ère des médias sociaux puis des
nouvelles 24 heures est ce que ça change
quelque chose dans la façon avec
laquelle on les lit les pays de
l'occident réagissent ou avec laquelle
les décideurs doivent
répondent rapidement
parce que c'est difficile maintenant de
voir les images sont elles qui arrive
sur twitter puis de
d'entendre aucun commentaire de justin
trudeau par exemple si ça fait deux
poids deux mesures alors il y aura c'est
sûr plein d'études qui sont en fait si
les étudiants se cherche pour un
doctorat sujet de la non ils en ont un
formidable
potentiellement oui c'est sûr que là
cette médiatisation grâce aux réseaux
sociaux et aux chaînes d'info en continu
permet d'avoir une conscience en temps
réel de ce qui se passe et permet à
zielinski utilise très bien voilà les
réseaux sociaux voilà de mobiliser ça
c'est évident est ce qu'un eux seuls les
réseaux sociaux contribuent à
modifier la dynamique du conflit je suis
moins certain par rapport à un autre
enjeu disais tout à l'heure une guerre
c'est un accélérateur tout va plus vite
pendant une guerre et ça ça toujours été
le cas médias sociaux chaîne
d'information continue ou pas mais là
oui ça fait que chacun d'entre nous on
peut suivre alors avec prudence
évidemment
pouvoir la désinformation et de
propagande mais on peut suivre ce qui se
passe en direct être touchés et par la
mobilisation entre les réseaux sociaux
ça mais oui probablement une pression
sur les décideurs politiques par exemple
pour que le canada envoie du matériel
militaire peut-être qu'il n'aurait pas
fait mais on peut aussi imaginer qu
avant tout c'est la résistance
ukrainienne moi qui fais quand on la
voit le matériel est que à travers les
réseaux sociaux les gens
[Musique]
et se mobilisent et il ya les bonnes
vieilles
mobilisation classique les grandes
manifestations on a la mine ouizguen
dans les pays européens des
manifestations
assez colossal au canada ça pourrait
plus voilà je pense
pour avoir été à la manifestation de
dimanche a ici à montréal c'était bien
de voir des gens mobilisés
je pense qu'on ne devrait plus se
mobiliser honnêtement pas ce que je dis
tout à l'heure ce combat c'est aussi le
l'autre quelque part ils font pour nous
quelque chose qu on espère ne pas avoir
à faire plus tard donc ça devrait
susciter une certaine mobilisation
j'ai l'impression qu'une partie quand
même du combo qui qui se joue en ligne
certaine façon sur le
le la propagation je demande
d'information puis de fausses
informations ici je passe commande il y
avait une nouvelle qui comme de quitter
sortie que qui avait tombé par exemple
qui en réalité cette pauvre et qui ce
genre d'information le ca serait pas
assez pour avoir des répercussions mort
est réel sur le moral des des milices
par exemple petites choses comme ça puis
versez dans le côté le contrôle de
l'information en russie si elle avait pu
tisser les mobiliser autant de autant de
personnes à soutenir cette cause le camp
qui ont connu toutes les informations
donc il ya vraiment il ya vraiment une
guerre qui se joue là aussi ah oui oui
oui oui alors ce qui est assez fascinant
sur le front de cette guerre de
l'information de cette guerre dans le
cyberespace par exemple c'est que on a
longtemps au cours des dernières années
l'homme étant depuis 2016 et le
référendum sur le break sinon
royaume-uni l'élection de trump on l'a
longtemps considéré que les russes
étaient des maîtres dans la
désinformation et l'exploitation des
vulnérabilités des démocraties
occidentales on propage en faisant la
propagation de mauvaises informations
des informations des informations
fausses
c'est vrai qu'il avait
un certain talent pour faire ça mais là
ce conflit nous montre que finalement
ils sont pas si bons que ça
et que là aussi les gens qui veulent
défendre la démocratie les valeurs
libérales mais peuvent contre-attaqué là
dedans et ils sont très bons et les
ukrainiens sont excessivement bon
là dedans a encore une fois zielinski
les quelques vidéos qui fait simple pour
répondre à la désinformation qu'il
aurait quitté le pays
pro mobilisés il parle oui aux
ukrainiens mais il parle aussi à la
communauté
voilà chez l'achat
avec mes proches en tenue militaire je
suis prêt à
me sacrifier littéralement
whissell toujours en guerre se joue par
l'image les les super héros par exemple
20 maintenant super héros ont été créés
aussi dans cette perspective le captain
america
les réseaux sociaux permettent de faire
la même chose à un coût moins élevé que
d'avoir
le sens ça devient tout est aujourd'hui
presque impossible à contrôler
parfaitement l'information le tir à
l'époque le deuxième guerre mondiale par
exemple contrôler les médias et les
journaux c'étaient les seuls accès à
l'information mais tu es aujourd'hui on
peut se douter que la jeunesse russe le
ils doivent pas écouter les médias
traditionnels russes contrôlées par le
gouvernement ils doivent avoir des vpn
pour garder les nouvelles partout dans
le monde j'imagine oui c'est faisable
alors que le gouvernement russe est
quand même investi massivement pour
déjà avoir un appareil médiatique à sa
solde on pense notamment aux fameuses
chaînes groupe intel spoutnik ou rachat
today rt qui sont d'ailleurs marqué
d'interdît ou sanctionnés d'un terreau
diffusion je pense que les européens
comptent des 6 décembre voir si le
canada fait la même chose
on peut-être mettre des employés qui
décide de quitter de même ça c'est
encore marié peut-être qu'elle va leur
interdire la diffusion en passant
mais oui
le contrôle de l'information est
beaucoup plus dur aujourd'hui même quand
vous êtes un résultat taurian qui a donc
investi massivement dans un appareil de
propagande qui essaye de contrôler le
plus possible l'internet qui n'hésite
pas à éliminer physiquement à tuer des
journalistes
poutine son régime n'est quand même pas
coutume et qui conteste votre autorité
marche peut-être un petit peu moins bien
que ce qu'on imaginait il ya dix jours
voilà parce que encore une fois
qu'il ya des valeurs comme ça qui a un
qui est dans notre vie quotidienne on
les oublie ces valeurs là où on en est
loin et quand elles sont menacés
directement
elle mobilise plus
et je pense que ce qu'on apprend
aujourd'hui et à la dure face entre une
fois très très tragique c'est cet
ensemble de valeurs qui rattache à la
philosophie libérale
elle mobilise les gens bien plus que les
valeurs entre guillemets qui peuvent
sous tendant la gym dictatorial mais
c'est quand même incroyable ce que
je pense sur une parenthèse mais
critique des régimes comme ceux où la
liberté d'expression est aussi
évidemment réprimer convoi jusqu'à abat
des journalistes qui au 21ème siècle ça
ça existe encore des pics eux mêmes ont
fait du commerce avec ces gens là puis
on a des relations avec ces pays depuis
que si ça devient un peu comme une
normalité mais si c'est que c'est quand
même quand même étrange
que ce soit aux eaux
où vit ou su de tous mais que petit con
qu'on n'agit pas vraiment quand on
le sent ici que ça se passe puisque
c'est ici que ce qui est ce qu'on
continue à faire du business avec la
chine et que tout le monde est content
de profiter de ce business la n'importe
quelle échelle que ce soit les grandes
entreprises comme nous en tant
qu'individu on est bien content que
plein de choses soient faites en chine
est ce qu'on peut se les payer plus
facilement
ouais il ya peut-être il ya sûrement en
fait une réflexion à avoir là-dessus est
ce que ça veut dire qu'il faudrait
couper totalement les échanges et les
discussions avec ces pays là peut-être
pas
ses employés les citoyens puis
il ya probablement des citoyens qui ont
à coeur de
s'émanciper et puis peut-être que ces
moyens technologiques ont donné aussi
une fois ce illusion de pouvoir au
régime en place
ils s'imaginent pouvoir tout contrôler
parce que ils ont
pas surveillés sur l'internet et ils
peuvent contrôler et suivre les
déplacements des gens ce qu'ils disent
sur les réseaux sociaux
mais les gens y sont en général beaucoup
plus futé que qu'un algorithme ans
on n'est pas dans la business de faire
des pronostics encore moins qu'un
poutine est aussi difficile à cerner
puis à comprendre mais selon toi quelle
serait elle la résolution a plus haut
taux de pourcentage
ou est-ce qu'on en est aujourd'hui
encore une fois comme on dit au début du
pont du casse a peu changé à toutes les
offres mais qu'elle serait là
le plus haut pourcentage de résolution
de ce conflit
c'est extrêmement difficile à répondre
mais c'est quand même une question qui
est qu'ils font pour nous parce que
c'est celle de ceux projetés besoin qui
est ce qui peut arriver alors évidemment
on est encore très tôt dans le combat un
pour essayer de voir ce brouillard de la
guerre se dissiper il est encore très
très très très très épais il peut y
avoir le scénario catastrophe du conflit
nucléaire généraliser
cela me paraît le moins probable mais
pas impossible
et c'est encore une fois pourquoi la
situation est grave revière à quelque
chose qu'on n'avait pas connu depuis
1962 qu'on pensait avoir disparu depuis
à la fin de la guerre froide ans entre
1989 et 85 cents le scénario
cataclysmique
c'est ça ça arrive on va sûrement
regretter les deux dernières années de
distanciation social de confinement
les deux dernières années de l'as de
l'histoire de l'humanité ont été
utilisées a couru puis a confirmé ce c
c'est fou que ça soit une option qui une
avenue qui même plus probable mais qui
sont quand même sur la table ce feu et
c'est ça qui est ric vertigineux dans la
situation arrive l1 honnêtement à
les gens qui ont vécu la guerre froide
peut-être s'imaginait
pas ou feint de avait l'habitude de
vivre avec ça avec cette épée de
damoclès
nous pas ce qu avait pas de 30 ans un
peu plus mais qui n'ont pas connu la
guerre froide ça donne carrément le
tournis cette histoire là alors je ne
veux pas non plus déprimé tout le monde
à voile à n'aller pas creuser des abris
anti nucléaires et vous réfugier après
avoir écouter le podcast
on s'en va tout le monde dans le métro
voilà mais dans les obligés de le
considérer ce scénario même si me paraît
être le moins probable
le scénario optimiste
de victoire de l'ukraine
régime de poutine
renversé
le petit nice à on va dire je l'espère
il me paraît quand même difficile aussi
peu probable mais je vais voir un petit
peu probable que l'apocalypse nucléaire
ce vraiment possible de vaincre l'armée
russe et même si même s'il ya un
engagement puis une milice puis
l'ukraine se défend vraiment mieux qu'on
aurait pu c'est quand même rien
comparativement la force heureuse non
ouais mais tant que les russes gagnent
pas hyper lé voilà est temps qu'elle et
craignait ne perdent pas ligue 1
quand il ya une asymétrie de force comme
ça l'ukraine s'est quand même pas un
petit pays en termes de forces
militaires ce que je me trompe sont
quand même dans le jeu passe le top 20
des forces message au mondial 19e alors
qu'est ce que ça veut dire c'est flou
c'est pas faux en soi comme si parce que
je par exemple en 90 91 quand l'irak
envahit le koweït et qu'on a monté
l'occident toute cette opération pour
libérer le koweït ont présenté l'armée
de saddam hussein comme la quatrième la
cinquième voire ça va être terrible ils
ont été plié en trois jours mais bon
donc
c'est finalement les combattants qu'ils
font là la tension suis à risque quand
les deux chiffres sont égales c'est
l'armée qui défend qin gang
mais on est un peu dans cette partie de
risques là et l'a remis craignait donc
allier d'ukrainiens sont vaillants ont
été formés aussi faut quand même
souligner que le canada a contribué à la
formation des forces militaires russes
avec lui par action et me fiais là au
cours des dernières années donc ça
augmente le niveau de préparation il
aurait de plus en plus armés de matériel
efficace donc
à l'heure actuelle c'est difficile
vraiment difficile d'envisager que
moscou puisse obtenir le résultat qu'ils
paient celui espéré c'est à dire de
renverser le régime à kiev d'avoir un
régime
marionnettes qu'ils soient mises en
place à kiev et qui contrôlent la
totalité du pays ça ça me paraît
complètement impossible et alors le
scénario peut-être le quatrième qui
serait le plus probable passée une forme
de gel de la situation de retour à une
forme de statu quo ante et
alors on pourrait dire finalement tout
ça pour ça un retrait des troupes ou un
abandon de l'opération militaire russe
dans un objectif de renverser le
gouvernement en ukraine et 1 re
calibrage ou un recentrage des
opérations militaires russes sur ses
provinces sécessionnistes de l'est de
l'ukraine
ça pourrait être être une solution
raisonnable mais voilà là la dynamique
des conflits souvent fait que ça
ressorte sur quelque chose qu'on aurait
peut-être pas attendu donc quelles sont
les
choses à surveiller dans les prochains
jours
mais gardez à l'esprit quand même même
si c'est un peu du théâtre la menace
nucléaire russe ça c'est un élément qui
a même à garder à l'esprit à surveiller
voire ensuite l'effet des sanctions
concrètement sur la russie alors ça peut
prendre du temps et les sanctions c'est
pas fait pour changer le comportement
des décideurs directement c'est fait
pour donner un coup supplémentaire à ce
comportement là dans l'espoir à terme de
le changer mais il faudra surveiller
comment par exemple les rues souvent
réagir lors concrètement ils vont voir
que là ils payent un prix indirectement
il risque de payer un prix élevé donc il
faut surveiller ça il faut continuer à
surveiller la résistance ukrainienne le
niveau de résistance ukrainienne est le
quatrième élément b surveiller d'une
part
la
l'unité la coordination l'entente entre
les occidentaux encore une fois qui est
remarquable inattendu encore une fois
d'une part et voir aussi comment
d'autres pays on évoquer la chine tout à
l'heure peuvent peuvent réagir on peut
par exemple imaginer scénario que c'est
jean ping appelle vladimir poutine il
dit bombay inde
et menez une claire et oussalah moi je
commence à pas et me si la chine
commence à appliquer les sanctions aussi
le la russe dans les rues si et puis de
la ville terminaux et là là là c'est
fini les services ont imaginé xi jinping
après quoi quelques semaines après avoir
signé cette année les relations d'amitié
limite éternel machin chose dit ah ben
non finalement on condamne
parce que personne et que personne gang
band et
l'éventuelle guerre nucléaire évidemment
que la chaîne non plus grand jour la
chine est super mamie mais anne claire
personne mais la chine encore moins et
donc là et là ça peut être justement la
chine peut peut-être joué un rôle
d'intermédiaire et de dire non mais
regardez chers amis russes
et où cheikh la lumière poutine ta femme
paris tu as perdu tu pas parce que si
hulk et le calcul devient manis
l'association continue puis continue à
pourrir comme ceux ci du moment où ils
font le calcul que c'est peut-être plus
avantageux finalement d'être plus alliés
plus proche de l'accident versus de la
russie ça se peut qu'ils changent leur
fusil d'épaulé bah oui oui oui et oui
tout à fait et c'est pour ça que
diplomatiquement si vous voulez il ya il
faudrait aussi pas faudrait pas oublier
pardon car oui le front lutter contre
les russes dénoncer les russes mais il
ya aussi le front chinois et c'est pour
ça que je les tout à l'heure il faudrait
abaisser les discours un peu hargneux à
l'endroit de pkr et aimant l'art les
deux sanctions commerciales et de l'
équilibre et d'appareils d'autres
fabricants de cession je veux dire pékin
aussi a des choses à améliorer de son
côté faire preuve de plus de
transparence sur certaines phénomène
mais ça pourrait être une bonne option
si on considère qu'il est très peu
probable que en fait poutine et xi
jinping se sont donné une tape dans le
dos au début des jeux sandy pour mme et
watt en veille l'ukraine et moi jean
valy taiwo sera probablement commencé
d'ailleurs à
l'horizontalité si c'était sur lequel on
aurait vu d au moins des déplacements
oui je pense qu'un voilà ça cesse et là
on est dans la fiction la
cauchemardesque carrément à fond et
en oubliant je pense que les chinois
sont beaucoup plus prudents et
d'ailleurs au conseil de sécurité il
oppose pas leur veto ils s'abstiennent
les résolutions qu'il ya eu les votes
les décisions qui étaient près de
conseil de sécurité de l'onu quelle que
soit leur importance là où leurs
significations et leurs effets mais la
chine s'abstient ne met pas son veto se
positionne pas de se voir comme ça c'est
classique un la diplomatie chinoise hong
voir grand voir ce qui se passe va
essayer de pas trop payer le prix
et ils vont ajuster à long terme par
rapport à leurs intérêts
tant parler du retrait américain
d'afghanistan on l'avait évoqué fait
qu'elle la chine pouvait s'imaginer
mettez la pression sur taïwan en nous
envoyer les états unis sont pas des
alliés fiables non non non sinon on
décide 12 ans maier vous êtes tout seul
peut-être qu'aujourd'hui il doit se dire
finalement
par automatisme mal acquis qui soit tout
seul donc ils vont apprendre voilà
puis la situation actuelle où et
c'est la guerre le typique est qu'elle
est mort qu'on se tire dessus est ce que
c'est quelque chose on pilon encore dans
les prémonitions ne sais pas mais t es
ce que que d'après toi c'est son affaire
de jours de semaines de mois ou d'années
cette situation le alors à la base
lorsqu'on regardait le rapport de force
entre l'armée kenyane l'armée russe
le consensus était de dire en 72 heures
ça va être pliée
s'est pas pliée en 72 heures voilà ce
sera pas plié en cinq jours
et à partir de là on rentre dans une
période où on s'est plu
à prêtre est comme ça peut être très
long ouais ouais ça peut
hélas c'est pour ça que c'est vraiment
quart d'heure en heure que la situation
peut évoluer et tout ce que je vous dis
là bas
voilà ça sera plus ça et tant mieux
d'ailleurs comme ça va très vite
chaque semaine
mais
on est dans cette période clairement de
d'incertitude et
oui
si les russes sans tête à essayer de
gagner
il y avait encore plus de morts en
ukraine alors plus encore plus de morts
en russie du côté des troupes russes et
s'ils veulent occuper le territoire
parce que c'est à peu près la seule
chose s'ils restent dans un objectif de
renverser l'origine il va falloir qu'ils
occupent le territoire
là il gagnera pas ils vivront et on
pourra alors faire vivre la même chose
qu'ils ont vécu en afghanistan dans les
années quatre heures
voilà donc là ça pourrait prendre des
années
voire titre au charme presque impossible
finalement un storim cette occupation le
point et ça ça paraît peu vraiment peut
prendre un vraiment vraiment peu
probable et
les calculs les décisions qui doivent
être prises à moscou puis les gens qui
peuvent soutenir le régime
elles sont très importantes très
important de maintenant et il faut aussi
et c'est trouver un moyen oui encore une
fois il faut mettre la pression est très
très très ferme ferme mais en même temps
voilà garder une porte pour trouver une
sortie qui sont autant de venables il
serait convenable tout le monde parce
qu'il ya eu 10 est de nouveau cette épée
de damoclès de la menace n'est pas
négligeable c'est une des seules cartes
qui restent la main parce que sinon il
ya eu beaucoup de les plus gros bout du
bâton le pousser dans sa main non non ça
c'est
la seule carte qui lui reste alors c'est
une grosse carte en asie - quitte une
carte mais qui est plus du bluff qu'une
carte mais qui d'une part car
voilà un joker il faut pas jouer en
ligne
mais norman bates
il sait ce qui est fascinant dans cette
histoire là c'est que
ces autocrates
les gens qui les admirent il y en a dans
les pays occidentaux après tout il ya un
ancien président des états unis à eux
merci et pour pouvoir ce moment parce
que mercy ne pas pouvoir arrêter toute
autre histoire oui parce que là il
poutine a rien à personne parce et fais
ce que tu veux très certainement
contrairement à ce que ces visites est
une catastrophe
contrairement à ce que pense peut-être
des partisans de trump s'arrêter là
enfin bon moi à
ces autocrates et leurs admirateurs se
prétendent des grands connaisseurs de
l'histoire des grands intellectuels des
génies mais il tire pas les bonnes
conclusions de l'histoire notamment
une évasion d'un pays qui a pas envie
voilà ça
j'ai des collègues et des amis qui me
faisait remarquer que peut-être poutine
a voulu faire un peu avec l'ukraine ce
que hitler avait fait avec l'autriche 12
donc rattaché un territoire
historiquement unis à la mère patrie ben
ça va pas marcher les ukrainiens il faut
pas accepter qu'ils acceptent pas
on suit la situation
merci infiniment et nous en parler
puissent ils avancent rapidement on
invite les gens à suivre surtout
autorités actif surtout quand même oui
préparation oui oui j'essaie de suivre
ça et d'éviter de dire trop de bêtises
du secteur surtout que les écrits
restent where exacte et que la situation
évolue très vite lassé d'être prudent
mais merci mme cousteau erreur c'est
infiniment encore une fois vraiment
passionnante ça vous savez vraiment
éclairé la situation je pense que c'est
enfin une chose pour nous autres c'est à
dire parce que je les aurais pas
déprimer
une affaire que ça fait par exemple
finissons sur ça mais
je ne sens rien comme si c'était rien
droit là dedans mais j'ai pas pensé à la
cage vide ça fait cinq jours au fait qu'
au moins c'est soit de positif dans
l'histoire on va voir
du contenu excellent tu as tout un
podcast convient
oui
si vous voulez plus de contenu excellent
comme ce que vous venez d'entendre aller
sur une pétillante de pétion vous
abonner pour trop de leur part montrés
trop de la mouette trois pièces par
morlaàs par mois ils avaient les pattes
carte en avance acquise avec les
premiers de votre groupe d'amis à vous
écouter les podcasts qu'ils allaient
avoir pouvoir avoir une avance quand
vous allez tirer la dynamique entre les
amis sultan avons une avance sur les
jobs en avance ou des centres de toi
mais avec pétillante une avance sur
l'humanité complète en plus en plus
parce que leur chèque le podcast unis
voulaient nous entende josé davantage on
fait des encore moins de filtres à
préchac podcast avec là on vient de
finir de tourner le podcast on va en
jaser on va être pile et nicole non
nicole il pleut maintenant comme un fils
travaille à plat ce détail est là mais
on jase on parle de conversion qu'on
m'aide à voir mais ce si vous voulez
avoir accès sur
ben heureusement pour nous
malheureusement pour vous s'est excusé
sur têtu il faut s'abonner abonnez vous